[MUSIC PLAYING]
GAURAV ANAND: All right,
good afternoon, folks.
I hope you guys are
having a good time.
You know, today
is the third day,
and I hope you guys liked the
sessions over the past 2 1/2
days.
So probably-- this is the
last session of the day,
so we'll keep it simple
and short for you guys.
So my name is Gaurav Anand.
I am a customer engineer at
Google Cloud based in Singapore
covering the Indonesia business.
And with me I have Wilson,
who has flown all the way
from Singapore, from Traveloka.
So he will be running
through this session.
So the way we are going
to run this session
is we'll have an initial part
of an intro about the data
analytics patterns
at Google Cloud.
And Wilson will
share his journey,
and Traveloka's journey
implementing the data pipelines
and some of the cool stuff
with GCP and Traveloka.
All right.
So over the past
one year while I
have been talking to a
lot of analytical leaders,
I have seen a lot of
challenges which come up
when it comes to big data.
So the most--
I would say there are three most
important challenges which kind
of come up often, are these.
We all know the amount of
data which pretty much all
the enterprises are
producing these days
has grown enormously.
And that continues to grow.
So you need to have an
infrastructure which
scales linearly as you
grow your business.
You don't need to
re-architect your architecture
or your infrastructure every
three months, every six months.
So you need that level
of infrastructure, which
just scales automatically.
The second one being
finding the right talent.
So the way the
technology has evolved,
if you see the open
source technology
the way it was 10 years
back, the way it is now,
there has been an
exponential growth
in the set of technologies.
And having your
team be competent
across all those
technologies is a challenge.
Because, you know,
every three months you
see something new coming up.
So that also is one of the
biggest challenges which most
of the enterprises are facing.
And last but not least, cost.
So as you grow, as
you scale, your costs
should not linearly
increase with your scale.
So there has to be some sort
of cost control in place
so that you don't have to
increase your infrastructure
along with the cost.
Now, as I just mentioned a while
back, over the last 10 years,
the open source ecosystem
has grown exponentially.
In fact, I still remember
my days of 10 years
back, when you search for
Hadoop, the only link which
you get in Google is
the official Apache
documentation and nothing else.
And if you do that
now, you know,
there are tens and thousands
of links and documentations
and whatnot.
So the ecosystem around Hadoop,
Spark, and other components
continues to evolve.
But that brings
another challenge
of having your team learn
all of those technologies.
Having said that, there
is no single technology
which solves all the problems.
But that doesn't mean you need
to learn all the technologies.
You need to narrow
it down to few which
covers most of your use cases.
So pretty much, in
the room, most of you
belong from one of these
industry verticals.
And there isn't any
industry vertical now
which doesn't have a need for
data analytics or even advanced
analytics.
You might see
there are a few use
cases which are pretty common
across multiple industries.
And the biggest focus is user.
And what you're going to
hear today from Wilson,
from a Traveloka perspective,
is how they improve
the overall user experience.
Because the end goal is that if
you have a product, if you have
a service, the end user should
see what he wants to see
and not what you
want him to see.
So at Google, we try to make the
entire data lifecycle simple.
So we have tools and
services across these four
fundamental lines.
The first one, of course,
being the ingestion.
There were days
wherein people used
to kind of keep batch ingesting
a lot of data-- like once
in an hour.
You know, your data
[INAUDIBLE] once in a day,
and then you have a lot
of analytics and reporting
running on top of it.
But the way streaming
analytics has
grown over the
past few years, it
has become one of the
most critical components
of most of the businesses.
So if you have to
stream ingest your data,
you can use Pub/Sub, which
is our messaging bus at GCP.
But if you come from Kafka, or
any other messaging background,
you can use that as well.
From a data pipeline and
processing perspective,
we have Cloud Dataflow on
which you can run Apache Beam.
I'm sure you might
have gone through some
of the sessions in
the last two days
on Dataflow and Apache Beam.
And if you're coming from the
Hadoop or Spark background,
you can run it on top
of Cloud Dataproc.
When it comes to
building your data lake
or building your
data warehouse, you
have two options, which is
BigQuery and cloud storage.
Again, choosing whether to
have your data lake in BigQuery
or cloud storage,
you know, there
are some pros and
cons on that as well.
And, of course, at the end
is the advanced analytics.
So once you land your data
either in BigQuery or cloud
storage, you can run all
of your advanced analytics,
your machine learning, your
reporting, and whatnot.
So as I was saying,
streaming analytics
has gained a lot of importance
over the past few years.
So this is one of the
most common patterns which
we see most of the customers
using wherein you have
your devices, you have
your applications-- web,
mobile, whatnot.
And then you bring a
messaging bus in between.
You get to choose
between Pub/Sub, Kafka,
or any other messaging bus.
And then you use
Apache Beam on top
of Dataflow for transformation.
Or you use Spark or
any other open source
component on Dataproc.
And then you have an
option to land the data
across multiple storage systems.
So BigQuery is the most popular
choice when you have analytics,
you have a lot of dashboards
reporting on top of it.
Bigtable-- if you have to do a
lot of time series analytics,
Bigtable is very good at that.
In fact, you will see one
of the most exciting use
cases at Traveloka and how
they use Bigtable for that.
And again, if you want a
serverless machine learning
service, you run your
models on Cloud ML.
So with that, I would
like to bring Wilson back
to share what they have been
doing at Traveloka over the air
and talk through some of the
use cases and the underlying
technology.
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
WILSON LAUW: So hi, everyone.
My name is Wilson.
I am from Traveloka.
So for you, guest, who is
not aware of Traveloka,
Traveloka is one of the
online travel booking
companies in Southeast Asia.
We started as an online
travel booking agency.
And actually, we expanded
to multiple businesses
over the years.
So what we're going to talk
about today is basically
we're talking about how
is data to Traveloka?
How we use data, how we
solved our problem with data,
and then what is our
challenges on dealing
with data in Traveloka.
And we are going
to also give you
a brief walkthrough on
how we adopt Google Cloud
into our [INAUDIBLE] system.
And the last but not
least, basically we
are going to share one or two
use cases that we encountered
in Traveloka, and how
do we solve the problem
with our approach.
So the first that I'm
going to share with you
is basically what is
data to Traveloka?
So Traveloka is a
data-dependent company.
We actually use data
for a lot of things.
We collect data, and we
use it for making decisions
at Traveloka, for example
for doing business analytics.
And we also collect
data and use them
for [INAUDIBLE] for samples for
the [? message ?] system, ad
optimization, fraud detection,
and also maybe [INAUDIBLE]..
And these are some of
our use cases for data.
And there is much
more [INAUDIBLE]
how we use our data.
And these are some
of the examples
on how we're using data.
The first thing that I'm
going to share with you
is challenges in Traveloka
on dealing with data.
The obvious challenge
in Traveloka
is basically the size
of the data itself.
This [INAUDIBLE]
is not very small.
We are actually getting data at
around a few terabytes per day.
So you cannot really solve the
use cases by using traditional
data technology.
So another thing is
basically Traveloka
being a company that has
multiple lines of businesses,
we actually have a
diverse source of data.
So maybe some company,
they only have
one line of business-- let's say
e-commerce or travel booking,
or flight booking.
In Traveloka, we have
multiple lines of business,
such as flight booking,
accommodation, car rental,
and so on.
So we have multiple number
of teams [INAUDIBLE]
working together.
And we, as the data
team in Traveloka,
need to actually get data
from all these various places
into our single data warehouse.
The [INAUDIBLE]
data in Traveloka
is basically there are multiple
teams who want to use the data,
not only our team.
And they have all
their own use cases.
And we need to able to cater
their use cases as well.
The next thing that
we want to solve
is the system [INAUDIBLE].
So everyone wants
this data, and they
want the system to be reliable.
They don't want
the system to be--
they don't want the system
to be reprogrammed once
in every week, or
once in every month.
They want the system to be
as reliable as possible.
And last but not least,
especially the cost
needs to be as
reasonable as possible.
So looking at all
these challenges
that we want to solve,
we actually came up
with a few features that we
want to achieve, which is we
want as low as possible
the latency of the data.
So as soon as the event is
happening-- as soon as someone
does something in our web
page or in our mobile apps
we want that to be available,
accessible to the BI desk
bot, or reporting, or any
other use case that we have.
The next thing
that we want to do
is to [INAUDIBLE] to [INAUDIBLE]
of the system itself.
So the system needs
to be available.
And because Traveloka
is a developing company,
we actually use data to make
decisions in the company.
So if the system is actually
compromised and, let's say,
the desk bot or the
reporting is not
available for a few
hours or few days,
actually it's going to
cost a lot for Traveloka.
The next thing that
we want to achieve
is basically we want to
spend time on operation
as minimum as possible.
We want our engineers
to spend their time
building something
productive and creative
rather than debugging
applications, looking
through the logs, and doing
other things that actually
can be solved by other means.
And these are our goals.
And actually,
interesting, we are
going show you is actually
the initial data architecture
that we have in the past, that
is actually sitting entirely
in Amazon Cloud.
And this is briefly on how
it looks like in the past.
So basically we have data
coming from the mobile apps
or the desktop.
It [INAUDIBLE] actually puts
data into Kafka [INAUDIBLE]..
And then we have
Goblin jobs that
actually going to insert
data our databases
and do ETL in
[INAUDIBLE] or Spark.
And going to store all
that in our S3 data lakes.
And we are not only storing
data from the [INAUDIBLE]
data which is coming in
[INAUDIBLE] messaging bus,
which is Kafka.
We are also getting data from
databases like [INAUDIBLE]
or MongoDB as well.
So with this
approach, we actually
have a limitation
on the data end
to end latency, which
is actually, at most--
the best that we
can do for the data
itself is basically
an hour delay.
So if something's happening with
the app or the system itself,
we can only get them
data an hour after.
So looking at this
limitation, we actually
tried to see our
system [INAUDIBLE]
can solve our use cases for low
end to end latency of the data.
And that is how,
actually, we tried
to work out in the first time.
Our first use case is to do
stream analytics with our data.
So we tried to [INAUDIBLE] our
data into Kafka and Pub/Sub
directly.
And we built our
streaming [INAUDIBLE]
Dataflow and post data directly
into the BigQuery itself.
And this BigQuery is going
to be [INAUDIBLE] by the BI
tools and the reporting
tools that we have.
So, by doing this
approach, we actually
already see a number of
[INAUDIBLE] that we can see
in the previous architecture.
The first, and the
most obvious thing,
is the latency of
the data itself.
As soon as the event comes,
it goes to Pub/Sub, Dataflow,
and BigQuery.
It goes into BigQuery in
a few seconds' latency.
So if something's
happening with the data--
let's say you are
doing AB testing,
you are doing a
campaign-- you can
actually [INAUDIBLE]
data directly,
as soon as the
event is happening.
And the next thing
that we see from here
is basically the Pub/Sub,
Dataflow, and BigQuery,
is the first [INAUDIBLE] that
we try is try is [INAUDIBLE]..
So you don't need
to actually worry
about installing dependencies,
installing libraries,
not provisioning,
and other things
that you used to do when you are
using traditional technology.
The second thing
that you can notice
is Dataflow has built-in
scaling feature.
So you don't need to
actually hard code
your [INAUDIBLE] department
for your scaling jobs.
You can actually set the
auto-scaling feature on.
And then your [INAUDIBLE] job
will scale up and down based
on the traffic that comes.
And actually, we really reduced
the amount of operations
that we need to
do with our jobs.
And the performance of
BigQuery itself is actually
a lot better compared to our
SQL engine that we used before,
which is-- actually we
used [INAUDIBLE] before.
So looking at this aspect
that we can already see,
we actually decided to broaden
our [INAUDIBLE] of Google Cloud
into our library system.
And that is how we get to
the next stage of the data
infrastructure, which will look
like a number-crunching Google
Cloud.
And this is how it really
looks like in high-level.
So data actually
will come directly
from the apps to our end point
that we built in Kubernetes.
And it actually puts data
directly into Pub/Sub.
It goes into Dataflow,
same as before,
streaming through BigQuery.
And we actually also
do another Dataflow job
if it going to convert
data in BigQuery
to a packet format in GCS.
And we also store all
the metrics in our data
in Bigtable, which I am going
to talk more in details later.
And all of this [INAUDIBLE]
is done through [INAUDIBLE]..
And the good thing about all
of this if you are aware,
basically, is all
of this actually
already have [INAUDIBLE]
with [INAUDIBLE] and logging
through the StackDriver.
So you don't need to
worry about your login
library or your metrics
library, such as [INAUDIBLE],, so
something like that.
And we also didn't need for
anything on the [INAUDIBLE]
anymore.
All of this, actually, is
either service offered by Google
or is deployed on the
[INAUDIBLE] in Kubernetes.
The other thing here that
doesn't have auto-scaling
is basically a Bigtable.
And the other components, like
Kubernetes, BigQuery, Dataflow,
Pub/Sub--
all of them, actually,
can scale by the demand.
So you don't need
to worry about how
to scale your traffic through
the BigQuery [INAUDIBLE]
such as end of the year,
long holiday, and so on.
After we get our data
into central BigQuery data
warehouse, we actually
built our data [INAUDIBLE]
for [INAUDIBLE] in
Traveloka to use.
So from a single project at
our warehouse in BigQuery,
we actually built a number
of BigQuery projects,
as well, sitting in a different
project in Google Cloud.
Why actually we are going
to do that is basically
we want the
permission of the data
marts that we have to be
as [INAUDIBLE] as possible.
For example, let's say
I am from marketing.
So I have data of my
as revenue, and so on.
And I don't want this data to
be shared along the company.
So I can actually choose the
data to be private to my team.
And I can share the data that I
want to share with other teams
at Traveloka.
So we actually have one
project for BigQuery
for each team in Traveloka.
So effectively they can
independent to choose
what data they want to share
with the company and what
data they want to keep
private in their team.
And another is
basically why we have
data in BigQuery and
GCS, the same data.
The thing is basically when
we are doing ETL from the data
warehouse to the data
marts, we are doing
ETL with a number of ways.
Most of it is by doing
BigQuery SQL directly
for a simple transformation
like filter, join, and grouping.
And under more complex ETL, we
need to use Dataflow or Spark--
for example, for machine
learning, and so on.
And if we are doing
[INAUDIBLE] with Spark,
actually, if Spark
can [INAUDIBLE]
directly from BigQuery,
but their efficiency
for [INAUDIBLE] in BigQuery
compared to [INAUDIBLE] data
in [INAUDIBLE] is
still unmatchable.
So Spark [INAUDIBLE]
data from [INAUDIBLE]
is still much faster
compared to reading data
in BigQuery for now, actually.
And all of this data
[INAUDIBLE] in BigQuery
is going to mirror
directly [INAUDIBLE]..
So every analyst in the
team, they can actually
make their own desk bot.
And from the date mart
they can actually directly
query the data from the
BigQuery to their BI desk
bot and [? mech ?] desk bot
for the business [INAUDIBLE]
to see.
And this is basically
the high level thing
that we want to share with
you [INAUDIBLE] architecture.
The next thing that we're
going to share with you
is basically one of the
use cases of the data
platform in Traveloka.
And what we call it
the [INAUDIBLE] metrics
in Traveloka that we want
to share with you-- some
of the metrics.
For example, like number of
data that we get per day--
a few terabytes per day.
And then a number of batch
jobs that we do every day--
60,000-plus.
The number of tasks that is
generated from the BigQuery.
And most of these tasks
using BigQuery actually
is coming on a near
real-time basis.
So even as the event
is coming, as soon
as booking is happening, you can
actually see the charts updated
at real time.
And the next thing is basically
the customer data platform
is one of the use cases that we
want to share with you on how
we do analytics in Traveloka.
This is one of the
example questions
that the business [INAUDIBLE]
or other teams asking our team.
For example, when did
a specific customer
buy from us the first time?
What is this guy last
purchase from us, and so on.
And if you see these
kinds of questions,
you can actually answer this
question easily using BigQuery.
You have all the data
in your BigQuery.
You just query your data.
You do your select
star from the Bigtable.
You sort by the user ID,
and you get your answer.
But the problem is
basically BigQuery can only
do a partitioning by bit.
And it is one of the
downsides of BigQuery.
And if you are are doing
these kinds of questions,
you don't know the day or
time stamp of the purchase.
So you need to scan
all the time range
to filter for this
customer, and see when is
the purchase of this customer.
So you will actually incur
a lot of unnecessary scans
of the data.
And another thing is
basically BigQuery
is designed to be an
analytical data warehouse.
So it's designed to
do [INAUDIBLE] scan.
And the response
time is supposed
to be a few seconds, or maybe
a minute for huge joins.
For some use cases,
we need these answers
to be answered in milliseconds,
because this is not
going to be caught by people.
This isn't going to
be called by machine.
We [INAUDIBLE] an API
so that other people
actually can call the API
and get an answer directly.
For example, and this is how we
actually solved our use cases,
we actually posted our data
not only in BigQuery but also
put our data in
Bigtable, as well.
So we developed our
API in Kubernetes
and exposed it to our
teams in Traveloka.
So, for example, for our
flight teams, hotels team,
accommodation, they
can call our API,
and our API will actually
query Bigtable or BigQuery
to get the answers for them.
And why, actually, we use
Bigtable for our use cases
is because a few reasons.
The first thing is
basically we want everybody
to have [INAUDIBLE] scans.
This is actually one reason why
we cannot use something like
Apache Cassandra.
As far as I know, it can
only do a simple key value
fetching, while we actually need
much more capability than that.
The other thing is we need to be
able to cater dynamic columns.
And if possible, we want it
to be many [? surface. ?]
Just Bigtable can
offer it to us.
And it's also familiar
with [INAUDIBLE] API,
which is open source [INAUDIBLE]
API from [INAUDIBLE]..
And many people are already
familiar with that kind of API.
So we are going to show
you about example data
modeling in Bigtable
that we do to answer
that kind of questions.
For example, these are part
of tables in our Bigtable.
And we went to assess when
this specific customer bought
from us the first time.
So we actually stored the data
in this kind of data modeling.
We actually used the
user ID as the prefix.
And we append that with the
time stamp of the event.
So the event can be [INAUDIBLE].
For this kind of table,
the event is purchase,
and the value is
[INAUDIBLE] of the purchase,
whether he bought a flight
ticket from us, or a hotel
voucher, or anything.
And BigQuery is
similar like Essbase.
Sorry, Bigtable.
They store the data
in a sorted manner.
They do not hash the
key to store the data,
unlike if you compare it
with Apache Cassandra.
So you're going to
get your data stored
something similar like this.
In this case, we have three
user IDs, A, B, and C.
And the number behind is
the time stamp of the event.
For you your data will be stored
like this, in this exact order.
It will be the user ID, time
stamp, and the purchase.
So if you have a
data model like this
and you have a
question on I want
to know when is this guy
buy from us the first time.
So what we can do is basically
we cannot do a simple key value
fetching, because we do
not know the time stamp.
What we can do is
basically we can
define our [INAUDIBLE]
scans for table.
We can define our
[INAUDIBLE] scan
to be the user ID, because
we know the user ID,
but we don't know time stamp.
So we just put zero as a
time stamp, for example.
And when you are
doing ranged scans
we will be to fetch
the first row.
We just have the
minimum time stamp.
And you got your alphabetically.
We just do first time stamp that
this customer bought something
from us.
Another similar
problem is basically
when is the last time a specific
customer bought from us.
If you have this kind of
same data model, with Essbase
you can do a reverse
scan from the bottom.
Specify your user ID,
and theoretically you
get the last time stamp.
But Bigtable actually
cannot do that.
While Bigtable is actually
compatible with API,
there is some small things
that Bigtable cannot support.
One of them is the reverse scan.
So we need to actually
do a small work-around
to be able to answer
these questions.
And this is how we solved
this kind of problem.
So we altered the key.
Instead of using the user ID
and the actual time stamp,
we actually used the user
ID and the time stamp.
We changed it with
the maximum time stamp
minus the time stamp itself.
If you do that way
for all your keys,
you're going to end
up with your data,
but sorted in descending order.
The first row will
be the last purchase.
The last row will be
the first purchase.
And if you already have
this kind of data model,
you can actually do
the same [INAUDIBLE]..
You could do array
scans, specify your ID,
and you get your first
row as the last purchase
of the people and its details.
And this is one of the
example [INAUDIBLE]
that we do in Bigtable.
And we've got a few more use
cases that we do with Bigtable.
But we're not going
to share it today.
And the next thing that we're
going to show you Traveloka use
cases is about the data
quality and anomaly framework
that we did in Traveloka.
So what is the data
quality itself?
Why do we need data quality?
In Traveloka, like
I mentioned before,
Traveloka is a company with
multiple lines of business.
So the data actually is coming
not only from one source.
It's coming from multiple
sources and multiple streams.
So if everything
is going smooth,
data is coming direct
to us in correct data.
But if something is
happening-- let's
say someone actually
deploys a new version.
Someone [INAUDIBLE]
an app, and so on.
And they forgot to put the
code in for the tracking,
and the data stops coming.
Or the data are coming, but
it's [INAUDIBLE],, and so on.
And all of this actually
can cause many problems.
For example, your
[INAUDIBLE] process
can actually fail at all.
You cannot see your reports.
You will see on your desk bot.
Or it's still a success,
but your reports, the number
will be obviously wrong.
And most dangerous one is
basically you don't know that,
but that is happening.
You trust your desk bot.
You believe the
number is correct,
but actually it's wrong.
And actually you are using the
wrong data to make decisions.
And how do we solve
this problem, actually?
Because we have all our data
in BigQuery, all of them
is mostly structured data.
There are tables, and
they have columns,
and each column has
their own data type.
For example, for this table
we have a few columns.
First of all, we have a string
column and an integer column.
And each of the columns
itself it has its own metrics.
For example, the string column--
we actually can
actually know what
is the proportion of naught
value of this column.
What is the distinct
value of this column,
and other metrics as well.
If you actually collect
all these metrics for each
of the columns and you
collect it over time,
you will end up with a number
of time series for a table.
So for one table, you can
develop a number [INAUDIBLE]..
The obvious thing is
number of rows of tables.
The next thing is basically
each of the columns
has its own metrics.
For sample, [INAUDIBLE] column,
for example like the country--
you have the number
of distinct countries.
You have actually a number
of null countries, and so on.
So if you already have all
these metrics from your tables,
actually refer to these metrics
to determine whether your table
is correct or not.
For example, when you have
these kind of metrics,
you can actually detect--
let's say that your data
has stopped coming at all.
You're going to notice
the number of rows
actually is dropping.
Or let's say someone is
[INAUDIBLE] your mobile apps.
And it forgot to put
some code in the country.
So all your country
will become null.
But when I say in normal days
you have 10 countries coming
to [INAUDIBLE] data--
you have Singapore, Indonesia,
Malaysia, and so on.
And then suddenly one day
you only have two countries.
And you know something
is happening.
And maybe the number is
wrong, and some other thing
is going on.
So by having all this
metadata of your data,
you can actually analyze your
time series off your table.
And it's reminding
where your data is from.
And this is actually how
we built our approach
to solve this.
This is the same BigQuery
that we used before.
It contains all the raw data.
And we [INAUDIBLE] the
performance of the BigQuery
to gather the data metrics
from BigQuery itself.
So we don't need to actually
spin up another cluster--
[INAUDIBLE] cluster, another
[INAUDIBLE] cluster to actually
do the heavy lifting for us.
We do gather all the
queries using the BigQuery
SQL [INAUDIBLE],, store
it in the Bigtable,
and use it for the
[INAUDIBLE] analysis.
And after you have
[INAUDIBLE] this,
you can actually
do your [INAUDIBLE]
on a time series using single
approach or a few approach.
For example, you can actually
do a [INAUDIBLE] mean,
standard deviation.
Or you can use a library
from Facebook [INAUDIBLE],,
actually is a time
series analysis
in Python from Facebook.
And some other library
that you can use.
By using this kind of
[INAUDIBLE] analysis,
you can actually analyze
whether your specific table,
or specific column in your
table, are behaving wrongly.
While actually this is not going
to cover all the use cases,
it's actually going to
cover most of the use cases
that we encounter.
And it's actually
helping us a lot.
The impact that
we can already see
is basically we can see the data
is wrong as soon as possible.
Previously, if data is wrong,
we don't know what is happening.
We know data is wrong
from the stakeholder.
Stakeholder, they see the desk
bot, they see the BI tools,
they see the emails, and the see
the number is obviously wrong.
Or the number is
not showing at all.
And they tell our
team, hey, can you
check something with the system
if something is happening?
So by implementing
this kind of system,
we actually know the data is
wrong as soon as possible.
And we can actually inform the
downstream user of the data
where do we have a data problem,
or whether it's a false alarm,
or something is happening.
And it's going to make your
trustworthiness for your team,
because people can actually
trust the responses coming
from your team much better
than the previous one.
They can get the
reports, but they do not
trust whether this
number is correct or not.
So this is one of
the use cases that we
[INAUDIBLE] in Traveloka.
And the next thing we're
going to share, too,
is the lessons learned when we
implemented all these things.
The first thing is this--
BigQuery has great performance,
especially if you are doing
SQL analysis with raw data.
For most use cases, especially
for most BI use cases,
actually you can solve
within using SQL,
mostly using group by,
join, filter, and so on.
For auto-scaling feature in
Dataflow and under components
such as Pub/Sub,
BigQuery, Kubernetes,
it's really useful to us.
You don't need to worry
about your big period,
your end of the year--
you need to scale up your
[INAUDIBLE] and so on.
It's all in the past.
And all of this [INAUDIBLE]
in Google Cloud, like Pub/Sub,
Kubernetes, and
technology itself, they
have all the
built-in [INAUDIBLE]
to the stack driver.
So you have all your metrics
flowing in automatically.
You don't need to worry
about implementing
your own [INAUDIBLE]
system or your own logging,
using [INAUDIBLE] into
some other system.
All of them is going to be
available for you directly.
So you can actually
do a debugging
if something is happening
to your application.
You can monitor your CPU
needs, your query in BigQuery
if something is running
slow and something else.
And I think this is more or
less the whole thing that I
want to share with you today.
And I'm going to give
it back to Gaurav.
Thanks.
GAURAV ANAND: OK.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]